[Applause]
what up Brisbane
[Applause]
sit sit sit let's do this
Brisbane thank you so much for that
intro super excited to be here it's been
a long week New York to Oslo to Noah to
Copenhagen to Moscow to LA now here and
I'm thrilled to be here Sydney tonight
so doubleheader for me which is exciting
first of all I want to thank you guys
for taking the time to be here there's a
lot of things that I want to cover in
our time together and then I also want
to really focus on some Q&A at the end
but really the couple things that I want
to talk about our mindset and tactics I
think the things that will really stand
out and and I have been following along
on social and Instagram and watching all
of you tag there's so much context for
what I talk about here I want to make
sure that I don't go into places that
you guys are already used to or you can
watch on YouTube I want to talk about
things that have been really emerging to
me lately and the biggest one is mindset
you know to me the thing that has really
become fascinating you know the reason
there's not a lot of content that I put
out between 2011 and 2014 if you go back
and look at the Internet is because I
needed to go run and build vaynermedia
again for myself because after writing
crush' and speaking a little bit from
2009 to 2011 I was starting to get into
a place where people were talking about
me and calling me a speaker or a
motivational speaker and or an author
which is super fine and an incredible
thing to do but for me my pride isn't
being a practitioner and being an
entrepreneur and being a CEO I needed to
build another 100 million dollar plus
business really to be frank with you I
need to feel comfortable standing here
and spitting my two cents on things I
think that you need to have an execution
other than ideas to have the audacity to
stand up here and expect people to waste
their time and money listening to what
you have to say and so I'm proud that
over the last six years I've been
executing vaynermedia and while I do
this garyvee thing Gary Vaynerchuk the
CEO of 150ml
our holding company from scratch is
exciting and interesting and it really
has become obvious to me why that's
happening and it's around mindset i I
think that there's way too many people
in this audience that are in the excuse
business iva and yeah and it's an it's
tough because I'm empathetic there's
always things you know you could have
two parents that were drug addicts you
could have lost your parents in a car
accident when you were a kid you could
have had your money stolen to you by a
partner there's so many things that
happen in life I'm super empathetic to
it the ultimate problem is though is
that the market the world doesn't care
right there there's so much dwelling
going on so many reasons why not and the
thing that has been really interesting
to me is that if you asked me what works
for me
its optimism and gratitude and positive
mindset like it's really interesting to
me life is pretty binary it's either
black or white it's either yes or no and
the one that matters to me the most is
you're either on the offense in your
life right now or you're on the defense
you're either coming up with reasons why
not all this technology all this stuff
that why not or why yes all this
technology all this stuff you're looking
at things and you're making a decision
and so for me a lot of what I've been
thinking about is mindset and why
optimism works literally seven minutes
ago in the in the green room I'm on the
phone with executives at vaynermedia I'm
getting texts of a scope that we
expected to sign failed million dollars
literally counting on a million dollars
gone zero not happening right another
pitch ruined a final two eight million
dollars didn't get it literally in 47
second step back in the backroom I lost
nine million dollars and I'll be very
frank with you I'm [ __ ] pumped about
it I genuinely like losing I like
learning from it I was like thinking
about like why what happened where we go
where it was the misstep why like it's
really incredible look when you can
afford to lose it and I'm sure people
are thinking this it's easier I get it
it's not like I lost nine million Vayner
lost nine million revenue but to me it's
not about anything other than mine
and so if I got anything out of this
I'll go into the tactics I'll talk to
you about social in a minute I'm about
to tell you why Facebook and Instagram
you know I did a lot of homework on
Saturday about the Australian market on
my thesis is around influencers
Instagram Facebook and snapchat let me
save you a lot of time everything that
you've been hearing me talk about how
many people you are consume my content
raise your hands
thank you that was awesome I'm just
gonna do that again how many people here
consume eye contact yeah so here's
what's interesting
literally everything that I'm spitting
comes obviously from an American centric
point of view that's where I operate
obviously we have a UK office we're
looking at Singapore we're doing other
things but I'm aware that outside of
Russia and mainland China most most of
this stuff that actually works maybe
there's a couple of different nuances
what fascinates the [ __ ] out of me is
the consumption patterns of the
Australian and New Zealand market and
the underpriced nature extremities of
what I believe in literally everything
that I've been talking about for the
last year you can add a additional
twenty to forty percent tax of up side
it is literally 20 to 40 percent even
better in this market and I get so
pissed when people are in any place
besides the US market or China we're
like well it's a smaller market it's
this Satya that's where all the upside
is you can only compete against what you
can compete against right and so I
believe that we are living through the
greatest era to be an entrepreneur ever
I think the Internet is grossly
underestimated and I think there's a ton
of opportunity but if you ask me what I
would want to leave with from this talk
today it's to shift one or two persons
mindsets you know to me it's an
incredible feeling to stand up here and
expect nothing from nobody and take full
responsibility for everything I the
Teleco company that gave it house and we
lost it and we in the back room the
eight million I spent zero days and zero
seconds on it I was not part of the
pitch I was not part of the process I
empowered all my people I saw the news
in the back room and I took full 100%
blame and responsibility I am fascinated
by your upbringing both your parents and
the neighborhood and those
siblings and the friends I am fascinated
by your upbringing the era you grew up
in the macro and micro climates that you
grew up in not the [ __ ] weather I
mean the economics and the politics and
that climate
I'm fascinated what made me my mom my
dad being an immigrant from Russia being
in America being in Jersey like like the
friends I ran into baseball cards
becoming popular allowing me to sell
something
I'm fascinated the environment that
created me in this completely emotional
place of enormous strength which is the
engine and the oxygen that allows me to
be successful in business and life and
then what is it that other people don't
have or didn't have and I see it I see
how my grandmother parented my dad I see
my sisters and brothers DNA different
than mine you know just timing and
things of that nature and so I'm going
heady for my opening spot because I need
you to understand to many of you are
gonna take [ __ ] notes right now and
think it's about a Facebook ad too many
of you are about to take a note me like
okay Google how to use Instagram
influencers we'll get to that I'm about
to talk about that but if your
foundation isn't right you have no shot
of long-term success if you're not in a
place where you believe this and look
this is super like I'm even like
throwing up on my to be very frank
here's what's happening my head I'm
listening to what I'm saying right now
I'm like this [ __ ] sucks
I'm being serious I'm being really
[ __ ] serious with you actually and
I'm saying that because I'm like man
it's so what I'm talking about is like
so hard to like touch right but it's
still my truth it's what I believe like
you're either on the offense or you're
on the defense you either see all these
technologies as the gateway drug to your
entire future or you're upset that it
was much easier to do this on email and
SEO and you don't like this social media
thing right I don't like these new
things either I built my dad's business
from a three to a sixty million dollar
business on email and Google AdWords I
didn't want YouTube to come along I
didn't want Twitter to come along right
I didn't want Facebook to come along I
didn't want snapchat to come along I
don't want voice and Alexa skills and
podcasts to come along I'm not looking
forward to the
our the problem is technology and the
way we live doesn't care about my
opinion or my feelings and it doesn't
care about yours either and so you can
walk around earth and judge oh it's so
sad that all these kids can't
communicate because they're on the phone
anymore or you can walk out tonight and
have dinner and see people at a table
and nobody's talking to each other and
they're all on the phone and you're
judging and you could talk about a day
and age when it was simpler and nicer
and all this nobody gives a [ __ ] and if
you don't adjust to the reality of the
situation you will be completely left
behind and that's it too many people are
executing or hoping or trying to figure
out how to live in a world that used to
be or the way they wish it was versus
attacking the reality of the world and
here is the reality of the world my
friends the cell phones that you're all
holding right now or in your pocket are
the remote controls of our society they
are the single most important thing in
the world there's nothing close
literally literally I would rather have
somebody roll up on me right now stab me
with a knife and steal my wallet then
lose my phone the world is being lived
through that device and you can judge it
you can do anything you want but that's
the reality and if you sit here today
and have any ambitions professionally
personally whether you want to sell a
course whether you want to sell a
sneaker whether you want to raise money
for the PTA a non-profit gets somebody
elected whatever you want to happen in
life whatever you want to happen in life
you first need somebody's attention and
then you need to tell them about it in
the written word in audio or video this
is how the world works and always has
you want something to happen you need to
figure out where the people are to tell
them about that thing and then you need
to communicate that to them in a
compelling enough way that they do the
thing that you want them to do you can
do that in the written word you can do
that in audio and you can do that in
video that is how it's been it was
called the newspaper the television and
the radio
now it's called a blog a vlog or a
podcast it's the same thing
nothing's changed except one thing your
attention is moving to a new place and
leaving an old place the other thing is
we have not figured out the creative
strategies to be successful in this
world the other thing is there's a lot
of people in here who are not self-aware
and don't realize they should only be
writing and not making videos because
they're not good at it or reversed or
reverse these blanket statements that
everybody needs a personal brand or
everybody should be doing video that is
ludicrous
what everybody should be doing is
deploying self awareness and figuring
out who they are
quadruple downing on what they're
[ __ ] good at and trying to get
resources to support the stuff they suck
at I've written for thank you I've
written thank you I've written for you
know when she was like he's written for
New York Times best-selling books I
literally was laughing as I was about
together this there's I'm like I can't
put two [ __ ] sentences together if my
life depended on it but I know how to
hire a ghostwriter and I definitely know
how to sit down for nine hours straight
and record a book in one [ __ ] sitting
right you need to figure out how you
communicate to the world as an executor
which medium some of you could do all
three some can do too
but watch what's been happening over the
last ten years in 2000 or 15 in 2002 to
four it was the era of the blog it was
bloggers how many people here were a
blogger from 2002 to 2005 at any point
raise your hands so some of these early
pioneers like they felt the impact right
right
you were blogging that was it that was
the medium WordPress or you know even
going back further like it was just a
very important medium YouTube had been
yet to be invented you know it costs too
much to stream video online there was no
video players podcasting then came in
2005 and six had a little blip but then
right quickly after that Twitter came
out YouTube came out and everything
shifted to short form writing and video
right and then in the last two years
audio has risen again how many people
here now listen to a podcast raise your
hands how many of those hands did not
listen to a podcast
three years ago raise your hands hold
them up actually you know what watch
this for visual we're gonna do this one
more time how many people watched how
many people are listening to a podcast
now raise your hands I want people in
the front to look around see what I see
all right an insane amount now of those
people are the people that now listen to
a podcast stand up if you did not listen
to a podcast three years ago I need you
look around because if you want to
understand why I'm standing on this
stage right now
I didn't say sit down I'm just kidding
again if you want to understand why I'm
so blessed to sit on this stage is I
have a unique uncanny get I take no
credit my parents get all the credit
ability to slightly understand what
you're about to do before you think
you're gonna do it and so what I do is
when I know something's coming I have
humility and this is a word that I would
love for people to look up understand
and start really becoming religious
about for all my ego and peacocking for
the ones in here who've been paying
attention it is my humility that has
allowed me to be successful not in the
way that I interact with you and being
kind because that's kindness in the
humility that when I believe something
new is emerging I take the perceived
risk of going there first spending
countless hours with no clear ROI and
the short you many people in here have
left ungodly amounts of money because
when social came along they said well
what's the ROI of Facebook and Twitter
do you nobody people here will lose the
next frontier because they're gonna
debate what the ROI is a buying or
building a 30,000 to 50,000 dollar a
Lexus skill or briefing for their
business a lot people don't have the
humility to take the risk of their time
I'm not even asking for money the fact
that you didn't have the humility to
waste three hours a day even though you
had the audacity to want to be a
entrepreneur that lived on your own
terms
fascinates me
I'm gonna repeat that statement for all
of you again the fact that you don't
have the humility to try the new stuff
because your time is so valuable yet in
parallel you have the audacity to want
to live a life where you don't work for
anybody and you make your own blows my
mind until I die and I expect to win the
whole thing until I die I will never
deploy the audacity of the situation
that I've asked for which is I've asked
for the loneliness of being a number one
I've asked to be able to choose my path
on an everyday basis I've asked to be an
entrepreneur and I know that you don't
get to hang out or rest on your laurels
literally literally everything I've done
up until an hour ago is completely
irrelevant to where I'm going next and
so many people get some a little level
of success and start thinking there's
somebody I looked at a couple of you who
tweeted me and like pumped and can't
wait to see this and then I went and
they're hungry and they're gonna do it
and their bio says I'm gonna be this and
that and then I look at your Instagram
and you've got 11 14 23 thousand
followers and you haven't replied to a
single person that's left a comment on a
post in the last year because you think
you're somebody and so I believe that
once you get your mindset right of
accountability empathy gratitude
humility that all of a sudden what I'm
about to talk about next makes a hell of
a lot more sense which is the following
my friends if you do not spend 2018
completely and obsessively around
Facebook and Instagram you will lose let
me say this let me I'm making this very
simple very black-and-white very [ __ ]
basic if you do not spend next year
completely obsessing over how you become
successful on Facebook and Instagram you
will be disproportionately less likely
to win because the ungodly amount of
attention of regardless of where your
consumer is regardless of the age if you
use those two platforms
we'll cover the far majority of what
you're targeting if you're targeting
under 20 year olds then I'll start
getting a little more comfortable with a
disproportionate snapchat and Instagram
audience but if you were targeting
literally 20 and above twenty to a
hundred I don't want to you guys the
number one converter for me on Facebook
across our clients my investments and my
audience are 50 to 80 year olds on
Facebook because there's something
called stream time and do you know what
happens you know the difference here is
a 29 year old on Facebook here's a 68
year old do you know the difference they
consume the videos and the pictures and
the words to a higher degree and so I
really need you to wrap your head around
the fact that Facebook and Instagram
have ungodly attention that the ad
product on those two platforms are
disproportionally underpriced and that
that is where you should be trading not
because I like Facebook or Instagram but
because I want to be historically
correct and I have one real micro regret
in my business career not passing on
uber in the angel rounds not other
things because those things are kind of
come and go there's a lot of variables
that go into it no the one time when I
knew what I was doing but I didn't go
all-in when I was building my dad's
liquor store Google AdWords came out and
I bought every wine term for five cents
a click and I owned every wine term you
can imagine for five and 10 cents a
click from Australian wine tuberosa
Valley right - you know Penfolds Grange
1994 like every SKU top-middle
like understand I was getting customers
for 40 to 80 cents apiece that were
worth 10 15 dollars for me but I
couldn't wrap my head around how special
that moment was I was young right I
didn't have experience I was just
learning about print and outdoor and
Direct Mail was all working because of
the macro product I created price wise
and selection wise but I sit back and
when I hear I built dad's store from 3
to 6
the million and everyone's like hey I'm
like [ __ ] that guy
that guy should have built it from 3 to
250 million if he was smart enough to
take his energy and money away from
print and radio and television and
Direct Mail and put it all into Google
because Google had that moment where it
was grossly underpriced my friends who
was the biggest advertiser on Google
from 2002 to 2008 Amazon Amazon was the
number one advertiser on that platform
in the early days they siphoned
underpriced attention to themselves and
now they've built one of the biggest
companies in the world who's one of the
biggest advertisers in the last five
years on Facebook a shopping app called
wish how many people here are familiar
with wish raise your hands raise them
high I want people to see this if I did
this three years ago nobody would have
raised their hands they are now a
multi-billion dollar retailer that spent
all of their money until recently now
they're doing like the Mayweather and
McGregor fights sponsorship and the
Lakers and they're doing kind of
branding stuff because they've so
penetrated to billions of dollars on
Facebook they were former Google
engineers on the ad product quit making
millions of dollars a year and started a
company selling stuff and only ran
Facebook ads this my friends is called
pattern recognition I will do the same
thing over and over I will be a 97 year
old Yoda looking dude standing up here
and yelling at you about some cockamamie
insane and it will be the same exact
thesis that I'm spinning to you today
get your [ __ ] mind right first so
that you can then put in the time and
efforts based on your ambitions and
becoming a humble practitioner of where
the attention of the consumer is and if
you have a moment like we have right now
on Facebook and Instagram ads and
Instagram influencers you will win I
spent four hours on the flight DMing
influencers about my sneaker release and
my upcoming book release I did it me not
my intern not somebody I hired in the
Philippines my two [ __ ] thumbs at
point making tens of millions of dollars
a year because I've humility to
understand what needs to be done to win
and everybody's looking for scalability
and I'm gonna hire my 23 year old niece
and she'll reply to somebody on Twitter
and you completely downplay the reality
of what I'm talking about
you are grossly under estimating what's
happening right now and I see it by the
way I don't know you I'm talking about
the market 98% of people are grossly
under estimating how good it is raining
you will look back at this talk all my
content during this era there listen how
many people have heard me say watch what
I'm doing not what I'm saying raise your
hands good usually that refers to like
what hashtags am I using what why am I
using Facebook why did I start a podcast
now I'm gonna take it to the most macro
watch what I'm doing not what I'm saying
why am i producing so much content
during this era why am i flying around
the entire world over and over speaking
to this subject it's because I know what
I'm talking about right now is gonna go
away I just want everybody to understand
I'm making you a promise of a micro
regret if you do not listen to me
carefully and way more importantly go
execute on it you will regret that you
heard it in a passionate way and I think
we can all agree
I'm not hedging up here right now I'm
desperately trying to force this down
your [ __ ] mouth
right you heard it and I believe that
95% of you will not do anything about it
I mean this I think that 95% of you will
do a little something you'll run a
little bit of edge of this you'll do a
little something you'll do enough to
make it feel like you did something and
you will regret not going all-in how
many people here play poker good I don't
but if you do when you have the best
hand it's a good idea to go all-in
right now for the next 12 months I feel
comfortable maybe you last 18 the
biggest companies in the world are not
spending enough money on Facebook and
Instagram and snapchat let me explain
friends what's going to happen over the
next three years
when coca-cola when Budweiser when
mercedes-benz finally gets their act
together in the next 12 to 36 months and
take 30 million dollars that they would
spend on outdoor billboards and
sponsoring of the World Cup and
television commercials and they put it
into Facebook and Instagram and
influencers you reaching a 41 year old
you know mom of two living in Hunter
Valley who's interested in your [ __ ]
today costs four six seven dollar CPMs
seven dollars to reach a thousand people
when that costs eighty six or forty nine
it shifts I
I'm gonna you know I know that
everybody's got different angles
Facebook and Instagram and snapchat are
marketplaces they're not like going to
the Sydney Daily News where they give
you a price that's a bottom there
marketplaces they start off of pennies
and more people bid up the feed is only
one feed everybody's trying to get in
and if you want to get in it costs more
and that's why they become big
businesses because if they have the
attention more people want to get there
but the price keeps going up the words
that I spend five cents a click for some
of them are now $14 words not as good of
a conversion as it was in 2003 more
importantly you guys got used to seeing
Google's ads and you don't click them as
much as you used to back in 2002 when
you didn't know if it was just organic
results or if it was an ad today
Facebook and Instagram and influencers
are under priced you're in a feed
they're under priced and you're still
interested in clicking those ads in four
and a half years you're gonna be so
tired of seeing those ads and Facebook
and Instagram you're gonna click less
and they're gonna cost 20 times more
understand that is basically all I want
to say I'm actually considering leaving
but I think I'm obligated to stay on
stage
how many people here sell a physical
product like a sandal like a peanut
butter like raise your hands tonight you
go home you have an how many of you have
an Instagram account for that business
raise your hands great you go home and
you DM every single person using the
hashtags that are associated with your
business and you direct message them and
you ask them to send you a sample of
your product to them and stand would
they post it nine out of ten won't even
answer one out of 30 will post it the
others will ask you to give them money
to post it you should pay them because
90 out of a hundred of them don't know
how to price themselves properly for the
attention that they're giving you in
return right so influencer marketing one
more time people with products raise
them high and now how many of those
people who sell products are selling
them direct-to-consumer like your own
e-commerce or things that nature raise
your hands
okay listen for the hundreds of you if
you are not spending ninety eighty
Google AdWords if you're not spending
sixty five percent of your money on
Facebook and Instagram ads and Instagram
influencers you're leaving money on the
table blanket statement without knowing
every detail blanket statement if you're
not spending sixty five percent of your
money on those environments you're
leaving money on the table because you
have so much opportunity now look
everything I'm talking about is 100
percent right I know it here's my only
concern and I want to spend a couple
minutes on it the creative is the
variable I'm right about the thesis but
if the picture or the words or the video
that you post to put in front of each
other sucks you're not gonna sell
anything so the reason this scares me
when I speak about this subject to this
kind of audience is I'm not in control
of the pictures in the videos and the
audio that you're putting out but I
implore you to try a lot of different
pieces of pictures and videos and
written words spend less money on the
ads upfront see what's working and then
pour money on it too many people in this
audience hear me they get excited they
go and Google how to spend Facebook Ads
by the way all of you have to do this
yourself I don't care how fancy you are
if you want to be successful you need to
be the practitioner not somebody in your
office if you don't know what to do it's
called Google Google how do I place a
facebook ad three hours later you'll
place a Facebook ad it's not complicated
everyone's a fun I don't know how to do
it okay it's [ __ ] 2018 use a search
engine you know like it's you know so so
the picture and the video and the words
are the creative variable so please
please please please do the following
and this is where everybody makes a
mistake they hear this they get excited
they go and spend $5,000 trying to reach
25 to 30 year old women in Australia and
they just spend it's blanket and they
spend on one picture or one video and it
doesn't work instead what you need to do
is put 25 to 30 year old women in
Australia or in Sydney and make a
reference in your copy to the ladies of
Sydney you've got to make a contextual
context is the secret behind the content
that allows you to be successful in this
new environment context colours we
debate the first three seconds of the
video the headline the colors the words
the words are different on Instagram
than they are on Facebook because even
though you're the same person your mind
sets different when you're in your
Instagram feed and when you're on your
Facebook feed the psychology behind it
the network effect how to get people to
tag and refer their friends
this is [ __ ] science my friends this
is 2018 science social media marketing
and by the way there's no such thing as
social media it's a slang term for the
current state of the internet social
media marketing is the absolute singular
advantage in the marketplace do I
believe during a big time sporting event
on television that a commercial can be
seen of course do I think it's still
overpriced for how many look at it yes
because I know how many of you when it
goes to a commercial reach for your
phone and start engaging elsewhere all I
will ever do is chase your attention as
it is now going from video to audio I'm
Tripoli downing on my podcast and on my
alexis skills watch this you'll find
this interesting how many people here
how many people here listen to my
podcast let's start with that great
thank you very much
of those people how many of you have now
started listening more to the podcast
and watching less video because of it
raise your hands raise it high I need
people to see this it's a significant
number of people who in the last year
have started listening more and watching
less because time is our number-one
asset and if you can hear me while still
doing something else the audio is more
valuable than watching the video which
you have to watch as a medium so if you
do not have an audio strategy for your
business if you have not started
creating the podcast or really leaping
to the strategy behind building an Alexa
skill for your business
you were leaving an enormous amount of
opportunity on the table please please
please start getting your audio strategy
you guys are runners for the mics yeah
all right I'm gonna use one more minute
and then I want to start thinking about
raising hand for a question my friends
listen this is you know you know how
like you know how many people were here
or good at cooking raise your hands
raise them
it's pretty audacious bunch I couldn't
even begin to think about cooking right
it's not a skill set I have for so many
of you it just came natural from the
beginning right being an entrepreneur
more importantly being a successful
entrepreneur is a skill set right and
it's one that comes natural to some and
others not as much it's a fun thing to
be right now and everybody wants to and
the opportunity is very real I'm a great
entrepreneur but I think I'm even better
at consumer behavior and psychology it's
Who I am it's why a lot of you follow me
because when you cut me down you see
that I'm pushing positivity and a whole
lot of other things that matter and
trying to get people to do it the right
way be patient do the right thing today
my friends you need to get yourself in
the right place mentally and then you
need to get yourself in the right place
mentally because the thing that people
have not wrapped their head around is
that this takes a lot of work like a lot
a lot not a little something and if you
aspire let me just ground this if you
think you're gonna make a million
dollars a year
which is funny the way people throw that
out like everybody gets there almost
nobody gets there right if you want to
make five hundred thousand dollars a
year which would put you in the
disproportion top 1% of income getters
here in Australia if you want to make
$100,000 a year and like doing it and
it's on your terms and it's your life it
takes a lot of work and it takes a lot
of smart work the thing I talk a whole
lot about is hustle the thing I talk
less about is being smart because I
don't think that brings you any value so
what I do is I try to come and speak or
through my actions show you the smart
things that I'm doing and then remind
you that it's still hard work the
framework is simple this is simple you
may have not allowed yourself to have
the honest conversation with yourself of
how much hard work and how much patience
it takes to be successful but it doesn't
change the fact that that's the case
you've never met anybody in your life
who hasn't worked their face off for a
long time that's built something
significant it may seem that it happened
fast cuz they're 27 but maybe they've
been hustling since they were 13 in a
different way that gave them 14 years of
experience to be a winner in that game
and so please please wrap your head
around what we're actually doing here
and more importantly if you were smart
enough to be here today and I mean this
the fact that you came here today puts
you so far ahead of everybody else and I
hate knowing for a fact that so many of
you are gonna give up your advantage
because you like hearing me say it and
you like the way it feels but then you
leave and you don't do anything about it
so please Brisbane do me a favor go do
something about this talk today I
implore you it will change the course of
your career thank you
questions
you could pick anybody for to go great
how are you Gary what's up man
real good you talked a lot about saying
that Facebook and Instagram and all
these places that you're putting a lot
of time and money into now for
advertising is going to come to an end
what spaces or what businesses are you
watching to see what's gonna come next
so in general I like to tell people look
I'm not [ __ ] Nostradamus right so I
have no idea the one place I keep list
looking at is voice I keep telling you
guys guys voice everybody in this room
in five years we'll have voice-activated
devices whether it's their phone their
clothes their car the wallpaper in their
home that instead of grabbing a phone
you're gonna interact with voice it's
going to be frictionless you've got to
figure out how your business and service
interact in a voice environment it's
going to be voice right so the first
thing you should all do is start a
podcast if you think you can podcasts
are great because you could just
interview people even if you're not that
interesting or don't know what to say
you could just interview people in the
industry or genre you're in and you just
ask nine questions and then boom you're
done there's an app I'm not an investor
of anything as I am I'm not called
anchor which is a voice social app you
should look it up it's called anchor
where you can record it on that you hit
one button and a posts to all the
podcast platforms it's just so simple
it's the first way to get into voice but
bro let me tell you something
Facebook and Instagram are going nowhere
for the next 24 months I can't get
people here to spend enough time on that
let alone worried about what's next
until you're [ __ ] spending is all
your money and all your time on Facebook
and Instagram I have no energy to talk
about what's next you're [ __ ] up
what's now
Thank You redshirts you're in charge
let's go let's move quick hey what's up
Gary my name is Christian now just like
I'm minded business I do nightclub in
Brisbane I do that and I also got a
personal Brent as well - C for
nightclubs but what I'm stuck I was
about four months ago I started another
business pretty shirts and I'm sort of
in between should I cross Brant or use
the shades logo as the printing thing
and the nightclub thing what do you
suggest it doesn't matter thanks goody I
mean I mean I'm being Frank with you
like people overthink [ __ ] that doesn't
matter it's not gonna matter if you use
one logo or separate logos like it
doesn't matter where I use Vayner and
where I don't wine library or Gary Vee
or Vayner it doesn't matter
like I love when people want to talk to
me about the name of their business
nobody cares nobody knew what Google
meant or Facebook meant or McDonald's
meant or coke meant a name doesn't
matter what you do to make a name matter
is what matters right
so it's nobody gives a [ __ ] bro just
pick one and [ __ ] go so it's just all
about branding basically yeah it's about
the execution right like it didn't
matter if he called himself you're
wearing a shirt of a guy who called
himself multiple things
he was the notorious b.i.g and Biggie
Smalls and plenty about like like it
doesn't matter
execution people wanted to bait these
things because they think that's the
unlock it's not period yep this is
actually one of the chef's that I
printed well that's putting it out there
I figured all right let's move let's go
red shirts let's go give me some hey
Gary let's get some people in the back
at the end of your audio book askgaryvee
you said something hit me in the face in
a good way that you never met your grand
you granddad or something and I played a
part in the way that you document yes
sure sorry how much does that still play
a part in your day-to-day decisions and
why does so few people really get that I
never got to meet my Grandad's either
and I was like [ __ ] really
affects me so that's my question I think
it I think so few people think I don't
think people understand I think people
think I just talk like in 50 years
they'll understand that I meant it like
I care about my legacy that's why I
think about it like I only care about my
legacy when I made $100,000 a year I
achieved my only financial goal that I
ever had somewhere around thirty nose I
can be really cool to make a hundred
thousand you know like when you're
coming from humble that seemed big you
know so that was it
why because I always felt something in
the middle of my stomach that I had
something I care about my legacy I love
that my I love that my great-great-great
grandchildren are literally watching
this right now I'm long gone but they're
watching this hey Jeremiah you know and
so I mean that's cool I think it's super
neat like I think I have a lot to give I
think I've impact how many people here
to think and don't don't make me feel
good how many people here truly think
that I've impacted them in a positive
way and I look at that and I'm so like
but I'm not gonna be able to do that for
my great great grandkids but now I am
cuz if I can do it to you I can
definitely do it to them cuz they're
gonna watch everything imagine there was
film like this imagine how many people
watched a levy thank you could you
imagine if dailyvee was about your
great-great grandmother no fun that
would be
you'd be like oh [ __ ] that I do that
same thing that sheathe like you know
it's so cool watching my daughter do
things that I do like thinking how those
get passed on it's gonna be neat plus my
man do you know why I obsess over my
legacy do you know why I document
everything cuz I know I'm good and when
you know you're good both in your skill
and in your heart you're not scared of
the camera and so it matters to me
because I care about my legacy not about
the short-term money everybody's so
worried about tomorrow that it doesn't
allow them to see what's actually
happening here and that's why I always
recommend people spending time with
older people retirement home I'm a big
fan because you get to see regret and
resentment up close and it starts to
help you frame up a life and I did
something very weird I don't talk about
this a lot publicly and you guys know a
lot about me I spend so much time with
old people when I was little like from
five to thirteen if I went to a
playground and there was like a
grandfather visiting or a grandmother it
wasn't just a grand
other thing I would literally stop
playing and go sit with them and sit on
the bench and just ask them random quit
you know but but it makes a lot of sense
to me now because I'm Way more wisdom
oriented then I like my energy axe my
energy so micro fast and intense and
alpha and male and competitive you know
but when you start peeling away it's
very obvious why it matters to me I'm
only about my legacy I'm only about what
everybody here says behind my back you
got it let's do it
what do we have Hey how are you Jordan
good thanks
so I'm a little bit taller I've been in
your content for about 18 months
thank you and I've really struggled to
launch my business okay self awareness
was a big part of that I started a life
coaching thing a while ago and never
really felt connected to it my history
is one of drug addiction and car
accidents and I'm in prison yes and so I
go into youth centres in high schools
and I talk for free yes and that's
actually what I love to do I've never
found a way to brand myself and make
money because I feel like part of me has
got a shame theory under I understood
the family and the people involved that
were hurting my accident so I'm I don't
even know why I got up to talk but
listen to your facebook strategy I think
I want to make some videos but I want to
be really sensitive around well so let's
let's actually have this conversation
for a second and I appreciate you
standing up are you still in a place
where you want to protect the other the
ashamed part I feel I feel very
comfortable that you you just brought it
up so you are in a place where you
listen it's your truth you're on to the
next chapter is there still reasons to
hold it to the best because it can
affect others or are you still in the
last stages of being okay with putting
it out there I'm not sure so I crashed
the car you know nine one of my
passengers died part of our crew I was
heavily drunken on drugs and I've never
really been able to connect with the
family involved obviously they have
their reason so I don't know whether I'm
gonna stir something sell for them by
writing a blog it would tell first of
all I adore you for that answer
right and and the best part is it allows
me to give you a really good piece of
advice people are confused intent is an
incredibly important part of all this
the reason I'm so out there and so the
way I am is because I know what my
intent is you may not like it at first
you may think I'm cocky and a douchebag
I'm cool with that because I'm gonna win
in the end like you may type refer you
all started out not liking me because
it's more fun the other way right so
brother the fact that you have that
intent I'm gonna really try to force you
to do this you should reach out to them
call go ahead what's that I wrote a
letter great years ago telling them how
I felt wasn't well-received
respect kid do you think they're on
Facebook you know I blocked them because
of when I got out of prison I got sent
some unkind messages yep so wasn't nice
oh I unblocked them just I blocked them
to just move on with my life I respect
it how long ago was that 2014 so look
listen if you want to listen there's
only one way to move forward
it's reconcile the past right so you
need to do everything you can and listen
you can still talk about your past
without mentioning names you know for a
long time if anybody's watching
carefully up until about six months ago
I never really made it as clear that I
owned nothing of Wine Library if you
know only into about six months ago as
my popularity has exploded in the last
year a lot of people are saying well you
can't listen to him because his dad gave
him a four million dollar business and I
needed to eliminate that excuse for the
kids that wanted to listen so I started
talking about something I wasn't
comfortable with which was you know
talking about me building such a big
business and owning none of it I was
worried could shed negative light on my
dad to be very frank and I wasn't
comfortable talking about it so I've
gone 10 years being in public without
ever really clarifying it I've only
started clarifying it now because I
don't think it sheds bad light on my dad
family business as everybody knows it
and more importantly I have to eliminate
that excuse from the lexicon so that
people realize you know what my journey
actually
so they can work hard cuz Todd people
are really looking for the excuse to not
work hard and so anyway brother you can
tell your narrative and put it out there
without referencing the families sure
they could google it and figure it out
but if long as your intent is right you
need to start recording those talks that
you're doing for free putting them on
Facebook I have good news it's gonna
work out Thanks let's go back there if
you can hey Gary how are you good
now uh just sounds like a practical
question we talked about I think for
everybody put some numbers on it so say
a business owner here they had $50,000 a
year to spend on ads what percentage
would you reckon if you're gonna go get
real general yeah yeah I mean that's the
problem what kind of business right if
it's b2b with only $50,000 I'd go
LinkedIn and Facebook right if it's
selling t-shirts I you know to people
under 40 I would be 80% Facebook and
Instagram with a little bit of Google
AdWords of people that are typing in an
intent with all the people that like
have never used you know Facebook
Instagram and digital media before well
what would you say is a really good
place for for them to start as far as
you know percentage-wise so you go all
right
2 grand per month into that - great into
that one going to that I'm not gonna
cheat what you're trying to do here and
I love it yeah you're doing the right
thing the problem is it's super nuanced
yeah but the reality is is that like I
said earlier they've got to spend money
on it if you're how many people here
already besides Facebook and Instagram
spend over $10,000 a month in marketing
raise your hands raise em high so not a
lot right how many people here spend
$3,000 a month in marketing raise your
hands
right how many people here don't spend
any money on marketing raise your hands
right so you've got a lot of differences
what's amazing about all this is no
matter where those hands went up more
than 50% of their energy should be on
Facebook and Instagram that's enough to
start all right energy which means
either organic engagement and creative
cuz you have no [ __ ] money or that
percentage of your money go
learn test and learn test and learn yeah
Cheers let's get them can we get
redshirts key sir yeah could you go all
the way back there good hello how are
you hello my name is Robin I'm an
exercise physiologist and I run a
private practice awesome so working in
the health industry it's a little bit
harder to kind of push people to come
and see you because ultimately the end
of the day I want people to come see me
if they need my help okay do you have
any advice for standing out on those
social media platforms well look it
doesn't you have to understand this your
dynamic doesn't change if you advertise
on Facebook and Instagram or if you
advertise in the print or if you know
like they're all the same dynamics right
so are you getting most of your
customers from referrals and other
dynamics or how are you getting them now
mostly allied health and GP referrals
right so now you're looking for more
upside because you've got a b2b dynamic
that's driving to your business right I
would just put out tremendous content
that is the best advice you have for the
general public what I do I give away all
my stuff for my best advice do you know
me do you know any advertising and
social media agencies have been been
built on the back of my free content
that are doing one to three million
dollars a year right like just left and
right and it makes me happy it makes me
happy
that's something I'm doing for free is
helping others because I don't think
it's coming out of my pocket that's
where everybody gets confused people get
confused because you think when you're
doing something good it comes at your
expense it doesn't there's so much out
there I'm never gonna get to all of it
I'd much rather have your admiration or
you know you know love towards me
because I helped you so you should just
be putting out your best advice
especially because all you're getting
your business from b2b to begin with and
then that will create halo effects for
the entire brand because right now
you're in transactional sales funnel on
the back end you need to create brand my
advice - yeah there's a good way to
stand out give away the best advice you
have forever for free for as long as you
possibly can that's fantastic thank you
goodbye Gary leaves my name love your
work you're the king mate I work for a
big insurance company it's not my own
brand I'm not an entrepreneur I think
I've sort of worked that out I respond
but I really want to connect with a lot
of people I want to sort of be I guess
looked as in the influencer down the
track amongst my sort of industry I'm
just sort of having a bit of trouble
struggling to sort of get that going and
I was just lying whether well or just I
guess trying to work out different ways
to get out there and do it it's I work
in sales I don't actually sell a product
myself
I help people sell it a month's their
work so you're in a b2b environment
where you're training others or helping
others to do that that's right
so but what why is that a struggle
what's in there
that makes it tough for you to put out
words audio or videos on Facebook and
LinkedIn just trying to get the the
legwork going I suppose in the in the
first instance so what's the [ __ ]
problem
what I really wanted to ask a question
and it was a two-parter say please can I
get a selfie with you yeah we got to the
punchline yeah you can come on because
that first part sucked
all right let's keep it going who's got
the mics we'll come back up front in a
second guy mate
hi Gary I just wanted to say thank you
you got me off the bench I was some
listening I was out of the game I was
nowhere I was kind of dead and you
always talk about deathbed regrets yes
and I just started I'm just learning the
mechanics like I've always seen the
clouds but you made me love the dirt
good oh man I got mad love for you I
just wanted to say thank you because on
my deathbed I'll be a happy man
now the the question I want to ask sorry
if I screwed up it's a little bit
nervous I'm a teacher I know the story
of little guy who really well and one
thing I've said on Twitter before is
that if little Gary in English class put
a written copy instead of handwriting
lessons he would have gotten a instead
of a day what I do in classrooms is take
self-development and peak performance
culture
yesterday in a classroom with the little
girl she likes horse riding and I pulled
out audible and I pulled out crush [ __ ]
and I showed this little go crush it now
my question is this I'm a teacher I rely
on teaching or my income at that sort of
difficult stage yes tactics yes when I'm
in that world because some of the people
in the teaching world to be perfectly
frank pretty [ __ ] dull yes and not
particularly inspired yes how do I
I either agitate from within that world
and as risks to that involved in me yes
inside that it's a you know it's crazy
it's a it's a similar thesis to clouds
and dirt you're not gonna win that game
my friend so what you need to do is deal
with that you know be Clark Kent and
then be you know Superman after hours
you're gonna have to find a different
place to scratch to achieve that because
framework of schooling and university in
the globe today will not allow you to do
what you want to do you're gonna be half
pregnant the whole time I'd rather you
just become numb to that play within the
margins take it all is upside right
because you're gonna be half pregnant
take the upside of what you're doing in
the class as all gravy instead of half
empty and then spend all your energy
postgame in a place that doesn't get you
fired and you're like you don't [ __ ] on
it you just create another environment
where you could scratch even more of
that itch cuz you're not gonna win that
game and you need to wrap your head
around that and that's okay I'm eating
[ __ ] right now vaynermedia is not what I
want to do for a living I don't wanna
have clients I don't want to be back
there and somebody made a subjective
call
it's just that I'm eating [ __ ] half
pregnant to build a framework so then
when I buy brands I will dominate and do
what I want to do but I'm right now
deploying the most patients in my career
at the height of my Gary Venus where I
could be 25 to 50 million dollars a year
just being me and getting admiration I'm
eating [ __ ] and having clients and
dealing with operations because I know
what do I want to achieve on my deathbed
you should do the same but you need to
reconcile that truth instead of being
romantic that you're gonna be the one
person that changes the [ __ ]
education system thank you got it let's
get up here for this lady right here at
some point
Gary no Gary I just want to ask you a
question the start of you talked you
talked about family Gary my grandfather
was head of security for Hitler's
Eagle's Nest he married a Jewish woman
my father is one of the worst pedophiles
in this state in the last 10 years he
bashed me every day I've been through a
lot my life it's a bit of a miracle that
I'm here I do run business I do have
great wins and also I guess great losses
I want to know you mentioned just before
you came on this stage how you could
handle a nine million dollar loss I'm
just curious like I find that any time I
have a loss I sort of
go back into the things that have
happened in my life I have no family my
mother's five families completely you
know out of my life um everything I have
made of myself um so just wondering you
know how person I respect losses so look
that nine million dollar loss is gonna
hurt a lot less than when I read Twitter
on the way to the airport right now and
somebody who was brought as a friend was
like ah too brash for me I don't like
him like you know so like they come in
all it's not about you know the losses
come in all shapes and sizes look man
I'll be honest with you the you're like
a hero I don't know what you're I don't
even you know like I mean you were
talking and I was like [ __ ] man I wish
that was my background I'm being dead
serious I'm being dead serious now am i
you might say we easy for you to say if
you lived it like look everybody has
good and bad in life we're all born with
either an advantage or disadvantage we
either started with too much or we
started with too little and then
basically you know your internal
fortitude decides if that was good or
bad
I've sat with people that have ten
million dollars in their trust fund
crying saying that they hate their lives
because their parents took care of
everything
and they'll never achieve anything on
their own and no matter what they
achieve everybody's gonna say it wasn't
them and they think it's the worse and
they're suicidal this is real now for
somebody like you or others that start
with zero you're like get the [ __ ] out
of here ten million you know you know
listen man to be very honest with you
I'll give you the answer you have no
choice
that's how what's the alternative when
you have a setback what are you gonna
sit there and say it was your granddad
and your dad I mean you know that's not
true it's why you have so many wins
right so just practice
I just kept practicing blaming myself
for everything now I just default into
it I genuinely believe everything's but
I think it's drizzling here today
because of me
like I think I think you just have no
choice brother thanks Gary
you got it can we do me a favor because
I'm running out of time could we get
this lady right here nice painter sports
shirt in the front thank you you're
amazing I just have to pace because I'm
intensely nervous firstly I'm gonna
update my facebook profile to say that
Gary Vaynerchuk call me lady so I just
have two things to say
the first one is almost five years ago I
was left when I was pregnant my baby was
diagnosed at birth with Down syndrome I
had to quit my corporate job and I
finally went back I'm not gonna cry I
cried in Pat Flynn some of you guys were
there you saw it I'm not going to cry
for Gary Vee because you're my internet
spirit animal so I went back to my job
at the Australian Taxation Office and I
was there Facebook channel expert and
sorry if any of them see this but I
watched your podcast on one screen well
I increase that following about 25
percent while it was there I then quit
my job
and launched a course which was 5 months
ago launched my first company thanks to
you and also partly but mostly you and I
we turned over 275 thousand dollars in
core sales and I've now be able to
recurring income and I did that by
reaching out giving back and building my
community generously in the meantime I
built out my son's Facebook and
Instagram profiles with your help my son
one baby bonds which is Australia's
biggest modeling competition he was in
the Oscar gift bags last year he's a
beautiful little boy and we're having a
selfie I'm so nervous
so I'll show you his photo a few months
ago I nabbed Down syndrome awareness
calm what can I do to build his profile
because likes don't pay for his mortgage
so you're asking how to continue to
build his profile yes so I can build
this out really successfully for myself
but it's for my little boy he's got
twenty four thousand five hundred
Facebook followers I create resources
I've got a website of built called
Parker miles common domain or 3045 I've
got backlinks in Yahoo your videos get
picked up by Dukan and I'm Anna ties him
I just I'm so resistant I know what to
do I don't think you need to monetize
good cuz everyone tells me I shouldn't I
just I feel like what do I do like do I
need to cuz I just right so let's talk
about it when you sit down make the list
of the people that told you you should
monetize it and then put me on the other
side of the list because they make less
money than me and you make more so it's
just you know it's not even about
honestly I swear it's not about making
more it's about moral compass it's about
legacy it is about you know currency is
part of the equation the thought that
you have to monetize that is ludicrous
what you should do is continue to
monetize what you're doing be super
successful and you'll have more than
enough and you won't be spending the
energy debating monetizing that side of
it yep
I think I just needed to hear that
because the reason I built it out is
because community is everything and
intent is everything and I just feel
like it never really resonated so I
couldn't do a dog thing you would do
this listen I'll leave you guys with
this doing anything that doesn't ring
clean down your entire operating system
and soul because you think you need to
do it based on somebody's advice that
you admire or because you have
short-term pain in your life is never
going to work it has never worked it
doesn't work and it's just better to
wrap your head around enjoying the
short-term pain and I mean that like the
process in the Rocky movies that are
good is when it's shitty
not when he's in the fancy mansion you
know like like like that gentleman's
background yours like everybody has
diversity it has adversity and more
importantly if we put everybody's
stories on a table here right that
gentleman's story is pretty intense he'd
probably be very high up in the
adversity but here's the problem if
you're sitting with some adversity right
now it's yours right no matter what your
adversity is just having a mom that
wasn't supportive just so you all know
is pretty hardcore having an on
supporting mom is a unbelievably
difficult thing for the majority of
human beings so like we all have it go
ahead I think I'm already getting my
return on investment because I get
messages all the time from my
nurses have referred them to my page and
they're crying you don't answer you just
needed to hear a thank I did thank you
so I'm gonna read about Brisbane I gotta
go
I gotta get this Sydney I love you I'm
sorry I've got nothing but love for you
thank you so much for coming
[Applause]